más de 12 millones de ucranianos han
abandonado sus casas desde el comienzo
de la invasión rusa el 24 de febrero
siete de ellos se han desplazado
internamente buscando acogida en
diferentes ciudades del este o el oeste
del país muchos de ellos en esta ciudad
donde nos encontrábamos levy que es la
ciudad más grande del oeste cercana a la
frontera con polonia que tiene 700 mil
habitantes y que rápidamente dobló la
población se dice que más de 5 millones
en total de los que se fueron interna o
exteriormente han regresado a sus casas
pero siguen habiendo muchas personas
viviendo en ciudades como estas que
además como le digo se ha convertido en
un centro estratégico especialmente para
recibir no solamente heridos que llegan
de otras partes especialmente del frente
de batalla alguno de los hospitales más
importantes del país están aquí sino
también han sido un centro para las
organizaciones no gubernamentales a que
acopian esos productos que llevan como
ayuda humanitaria a otras regiones
y a pesar de que aquí suenan las sirenas
y han habido ataques en algunos momentos
especialmente a centros de acopio
militares la realidad es que es una
ciudad bastante segura pero las
autoridades han advertido que el
movimiento de tropas bielorrusas en la
frontera podría suceder un ataque
eventual en el futuro y también
advierten de que tienen un invierno muy
duro por delante especialmente por la
ausencia de gas y posiblemente de
electricidad